Hey guys, welcome to the cold open. Anything you'd like to say? No, Will, you can't start a cold open with a yawn. Sorry, dude. Sean, anything to fire up the cold open with? You want a dad joke? Yeah, open up the book. Okay.
大家好，欢迎收听开场白。有什么想说的吗？不，威廉，你不能用哈欠来开始开场白。对不起，伙计。肖恩，有什么好聊的来开启开场白吗？你想讲个冷笑话？行，翻开书吧。好吧。
Sorry, listener, just give us one second. Welcome to our cold open and... Did you hear about the cheese that's been working out? I didn't what happened the dude is shredded Hello, my name is Jason. Hi, Jason. My name is John. I'd love to pod with you guys. Are you guys up for podding?
对不起，听众朋友们，给我们一秒钟。欢迎来到我们的开场白，然后……你听过那个一直在锻炼身体的奶酪吗？我没有，怎么了？那个家伙练得超壮的！你好，我叫杰森。嗨，杰森。我叫约翰。我很想和你们一起录播客。你们想录播客吗？
Sure. Let's get this podding starting. Let's get this podding starting. That's a good one. I never heard that. Let's get this podding started. Anything worth talking about in your... I looked up right before this, I was looking up how to survive in your life.
当然。让我们开始录播客吧。让我们开始录播客吧。这个不错。我从来没听过。让我们开始录播客吧。有什么值得在你的……我在这之前刚查过，我当时在查如何在生活中生存。
How to survive in your life. How to survive in your life. How to survive in your life. How to survive in your life. How to survive in your life. How to survive in your life. How to survive in your life. How to survive in your life. How to survive in your that. Let's get this party started. Anything worth talking about? I looked up right before this,
如何在生活中生存。如何在生活中生存。如何在生活中生存。如何在生活中生存。如何在生活中生存。如何在生活中生存。如何在生活中生存。如何在生活中生存。如何在生活中生存那个。让我们开始派对吧。有什么值得聊的吗？我在这之前刚查过，
I was looking up how to survive a nuclear war. Mark 7 Jason had a good one. Uh huh, we gotta mark it down. Sorry. Sorry. No. Will, anything exciting in your life today? No.
我当时在查如何在一场核战争中生存。马克 7 杰森想得真好。嗯哼，我们得记下来。对不起。对不起。不。威廉，你今天的生活有什么让人兴奋的吗？没有。
This morning? Still just in recovery. Wanna know how to survive a nuclear war? Oh right, you're still trying to kick your virus. Yeah. Sean, what were you saying? You wanna win? Do you wanna know how to survive a nuclear war?
今天早上？还在恢复中。想知道如何在一场核战争中生存吗？哦对，你还在试图戒掉你的病毒。对。肖恩，你刚才说什么？你想赢吗？你想知道如何在一场核战争中生存吗？
Or a nuclear bomb? Okay. Run? So you've gotta cover your eyes and get down, and then you gotta find a basement or something. Okay, man. And we'll be right back. I mean. Because I read a headline this morning when I got up, Okay man. And we'll be right back.
还是一颗原子弹？好吧。逃跑？所以你得捂住眼睛然后趴下，接着你得找个地下室什么的。好吧，老兄。我们马上回来。我是说。因为我今天早上起床时看到了一条头条，好吧老兄。我们马上回来。
Because I read a headline this morning when I got up, North Korea is ready to, they're always saying whatever. You know we're doing a happy feel good live cast here? I'd like just to say really quick, Jason. Okay, sorry, do you want to make a statement? I do. I would just like to say, um... If I can get in here. Wait, Willie's got a really, we got a really fast, uh, good joke for Jason today. Uh...
因为我今天早上起床时看到了一条头条，朝鲜准备去，他们总是随便说说。你知道我们这里正在录制一个轻松愉快的直播吗？杰森，我想简单说两句。好的，抱歉，你想发表个声明吗？是的。我只想说，嗯……如果我能插话的话。等等，威利有一个非常，我们今天有一个非常快、嗯，很好的笑话要讲给杰森听。呃……
Well, about the fact that, that, uh, dogs can't do MRIs, but cats can. Okay, so here we go. Great. Did you guys get on early? We both watched the same TikTok video. Oh, no. I don't have the TikTok. Anyway, Sean's got a few written down. Go ahead, Sean, he wrote them down. By the way, he went back and he wrote them down.
嗯，关于这样一个事实，就是，嗯，狗狗不能做核磁共振，但猫可以。好吧，开始吧。太棒了。你们俩很早就到了吗？我们都看了同一个 TikTok 视频。哦，不。我没有 TikTok。不管怎样，肖恩写了几个下来。说吧，肖恩，他把它们写下来了。顺便说一句，他回去把它们写了下来。
Go ahead, Sean. I know, you wanna hear another one? Milk is the fastest liquid on earth. It's pasteurized before we can even see it. Not bad. Okay. Anything else you wanna help the people driving to finish off their car accident with?
说吧，肖恩。我知道，你想听另一个吗？牛奶是世界上最快的液体。它在我们看到它之前就已经巴氏杀菌了。还不错。好吧。还有什么你想帮那些开车的人在车祸中结束生命的吗？
No, because they're gonna get super excited about our guest today. And now listen, I love when we get a true living legend on this podcast. My guest today served our country in the Air Force, became a renowned jazz musician, and then eventually moved to Hollywood to work on some of the biggest films in motion picture history
不，因为他们会对我们今天的嘉宾超级兴奋。现在听着，我最喜欢在这档播客里请到真正的活着的传奇人物了。我今天的嘉宾曾在空军为我们的国家服务，成为了一位著名的爵士音乐家，后来又搬到好莱坞，参与制作了电影史上一些最伟大的电影。
I'm sure you're gonna guess who it is right away He is the single most Academy Award nominated living person and after Walt Disney He's the second most nominated person of all time anyone in the world from all walks of life could hum his work guys It's the illustrious and comparable one of my heroes John Williams. Got it. Yes This is so cool unbelievable incomparable, one of my heroes, John Williams. Got it! No way! Yes, incredible. Wow! Look at this! Wow! Good day, sir.
我相信你马上就能猜出他是谁了他是获得奥斯卡提名最多的在世个人除了华特·迪斯尼之后 他是史上获得提名第二多的人世界上各行各业的任何人都能哼出他的作品 伙计们 这就是杰出、无与伦比、我的英雄之一的约翰·威廉姆斯。懂了。是的 这太酷了 难以置信、无与伦比，我的英雄之一，约翰·威廉姆斯。懂了！不会吧！是的，太棒了。哇！看看这个！哇！你好，先生。
This is so cool. Unbelievable. Hi, John. Hello, gentlemen. How are you today? I just saw pictures of all three of you, and you looked healthy to me, like three NFL players on their day off.
这太酷了。难以置信。嗨，约翰。你好，先生们。你们今天过得怎么样？我刚刚看到你们三个人的照片，你们看起来很健康，就像休假当天的三名 NFL 球员一样。
Yeah. I know, that's stretching it. So Sean, how is it possible you could play Oscar LeVance? Well, I don't know. It shocked us too. Because I don't look anything like him, I know. No, I know. But I studied, you know, I worked on all the things
对。我知道，这有点夸张了。那么肖恩，你怎么可能扮演奥斯卡·列万特？嗯，我不知道。这也震惊了我们。因为我长得一点也不像他，我知道。不，我知道。但我做过研究，你知道的，我研究了所有的事情
an actor should work on, the voice to walk this thing. Did you research a lot of things? I did, I read all his books. I went to the archives at the Paley Center, where they have all the old footage, and I just spent a couple days there looking at stuff, and then I downloaded some stuff on YouTube. You just go nuts when you try to do something like that.
一个演员应该研究的事情，声音，走路的姿态。你研究了很多东西吗？我研究了，我读了他所有的书。我去了佩利中心的档案馆，那里有所有以前的旧录像，我在那里花了几天时间看东西，然后我在 YouTube 上下载了一些东西。当你试图做类似的事情时，你简直会疯狂。
Did you have to go to the piano and sort of? This is supposed to be about you, John Williams. John, did you get a chance to see Sean do his play on Broadway? No. No, no. Oh, he was just incredible. I mean, you would have been very impressed
你必须走到钢琴前弹奏一番吗？这本该是关于你的，约翰·威廉姆斯。约翰，你有机会看肖恩在百老汇出演他的戏剧吗？没有。不，不。哦，他简直太棒了。我的意思是，你一定会印象深刻
with his piano playing ability. You have somebody who would know what to look for, this guy's classically trained, and he did the entire Rhapsody in Blue solo, on stage, on a grand piano. It was incredible. Sean, who did the first performance of the Piano Concerto of Gershwin?
他的钢琴演奏能力。如果你找一个懂行的人来看，这家伙受过古典训练，他在舞台上用一台三角钢琴完整地演奏了《蓝色狂想曲》独奏。太棒了。肖恩，谁是格什温《F大调钢琴协奏曲》的首演者？
Was it Oscar? No, it was Gershwin, but Oscar recorded the piano concerto of Gershwin. Was it Oscar? No, it was Gershwin, but Oscar recorded the most famous recording of it. Okay, fine. So, and that's what Oscar was known for, and he tried to, it's a very Salieri, Mozart kind of relationship where they, a love-hate,
是奥斯卡吗？不，是格什温，但奥斯卡录制了格什温的钢琴协奏曲。是奥斯卡吗？不，是格什温，但奥斯卡录制了它最著名的版本。好吧，好吧。所以，这也是奥斯卡闻名遐迩的原因，他试图去，这是一种非常萨列里与莫扎特式的关系，他们之间有一种爱恨交织，
where Oscar revered Gershwin, but could never be quite like him. The books are wonderful. His wit and the whole thing. I met him once in the office. Oh, you did? Yes, in the office of Louis B. Mayer. Oh, wow. Accompanying Howard Keele and a woman,
奥斯卡崇拜格什温，但却永远无法完全成为他那样的人。这些书太棒了。他的机智和整个人。我有一次在办公室里见过他。哦，真的吗？是的，在路易·B·梅尔的办公室里。哦，哇！伴随着霍华德·基尔和一个女人，
it's name I can't remember, and they were auditioning Howard and the Girl for Louis B. Mayer, and he had people from the music department, including Oscar. That's crazy. At this audition, and it was in Mayer's office where there was a piano, and I just came in, sheepishly, through the back door to company's people
她的名字我记不清了，他们在为路易·B·梅尔试镜霍华德和那个女孩，他有来自音乐部门的人，包括奥斯卡。这太疯狂了。在这次试镜中，地点在梅尔的办公室，那里有一台钢琴，我只是害羞地从后门进来，陪同那些人
and then leave before the discussion started. Really? I've always adored Oscar Levant. Yeah, he's... That's fantastic. He's fantastic. You know, he was a student of Schoenberg, did you know that?
然后在讨论开始前离开。真的吗？我一直很崇拜奥斯卡·列万特。是的，他……这太棒了。他太棒了。你知道吗，他是勋伯格的学生，你知道这件事吗？
Wow, you were? Oscar was, oh yeah, he was a very student. Well Oscar was, you said you were? No, no, no, Mike, I'm not sure. Well Oscar was, yes, I knew that. But how can I help you guys? What on earth can I possibly give you? You've already done plenty by bringing this to do this.
哇，你是吗？奥斯卡是的，他是个非常认真的学生。嗯，奥斯卡是，你刚才说你是？不，不，不，迈克，我不确定。嗯，奥斯卡是，是的，我知道那件事。但我要怎么帮你们呢？我到底能给你们什么呢？你们把这个节目带到这里来，就已经做得很好了。
Yeah, John, you just tipped the fact that you said that you were in Louis B. Mayer's office, which is such a mind blow. Yeah. This is, by the way, I'm Will. It's such a pleasure to meet you. For Tracy, he was a big studio head, like mogul. Film executive, yeah.
对啊，约翰，你刚才随口说出你曾在路易·B·梅尔的办公室里，这太震撼了。是的。顺便说一下，我是威廉。很高兴认识你。对于特雷西来说，他是一个大的电影公司老板，就像大亨一样。电影高管，是的。
What were those days like? What were the people, these old sort of iconic studio heads like, guys like Louis B. Mayer? What was your experience with gentlemen like that back in the day? Well, of course, I really didn't have contact or access to them. I did have a relationship with Lew Wasserman, actually,
那段日子是怎样的？那些人，这些老派的标志性电影公司老板是什么样的，比如路易·B·梅尔这样的人？你过去和那样的大人物有过什么经历？嗯，当然，我实际上并没有和他们接触或直接接触。不过，我实际上和刘·沃瑟曼有过交往，
but he was of a younger generation than the Warner Brothers. Jack Warner, I used to go to the previews of the Warner Brothers films that I did, and Jack Warner always went to those. I met him three or four times at those previews. He knew I had something to do with music. I never knew my name, so he referred to me as Beethoven.
但他比华纳兄弟年轻一代。杰克·华纳，我过去常常去看我制作的华纳兄弟电影的试映，杰克·华纳总是去看那些试映。我在那些试映会上见过他三四次。他知道我跟音乐有关。他从来不知道我的名字，所以他管我叫贝多芬。
At the end of the preview, he would say, Beethoven, we need a little more music in reel five. I'd just say, yes sir, we'll do that. But the other moguls, I'm afraid, were a generation beyond me. But what I would say about them, I think, is they were all ideologues in a way. Early motion picture entrepreneurs, probably a little, when I say ideologues, they were probably a little bit naive in their approach to the world. Yeah. Were they as showmany and as gregarious
在试映结束时，他会说：“贝多芬，第五卷里我们需要多一点音乐。”我就会说：“好的，先生，我们会这么做的。”但其他的电影大亨，恐怕比我年长一代。不过我要对他们说的是，我认为他们某种程度上都是思想家。早期的电影创业者，可能有点，当我说是思想家时，他们在对待世界的态度上可能有点天真。是的。他们像电影里描绘的那样充满表演欲、热情洋溢吗？
as they're portrayed in the movies, as these guys smoking big cigars and screaming out orders and stuff like that? I think businessmenmen more than anything. From Eastern Europe, from Brooklyn, from across the country to Hollywood, and really creating from the ground up the business that has been so wonderful
就像那些叼着大雪茄、大喊大叫下达命令的家伙们吗？比起别的，我觉得他们更像是商人。来自东欧、布鲁克林、从全国各地来到好莱坞，真正从零开始创造了在过去一个世纪里如此精彩的事业，当然，现在正受到各种力量的威胁，各种科技，以及不仅使好莱坞黯然失色，而且将其置于不同光影和创造力框架中的全球电影制作。约翰，你会怎么说，这是一个很好的观点，你提出了一个有趣的观点，在你看来，你认为对于这部精彩的电影来说，最大的威胁是什么？
all through the last century, now of course threatened by all kinds of forces, technology of all kinds, and worldwide production of film that not eclipses Hollywood, but it puts it in a different kind of a frame of lighting and creativity. John, what would you say, that's a great, that's an interesting point you made, what would you say in your opinion is the greatest, you know threat to this this wonderful film?
存在了这么长时间的行业，在你看来，目前对我们所拥有的东西最迫在眉睫的威胁是什么？嗯，可能是在电影和各种内容上的访问和便捷获取方式，无论那是什么，都可以在家里获得，对吧，所以在电影和各种内容上的极大的获取便利，无论那是什么，都可以在家里获得。所以，简单地开个玩笑，最大的障碍可以说就是交通堵塞
Industry that has been around for so long now What in your view right now is its most sort of imminent threat to to what we've got? well, probably the the the access and easy availability to all manner of things on film and whatever That is available at home right, so the great availability to all manner of things on film and whatever, that is available at home. So the great, just to flip about it, the great impediments might be said to be traffic jams
和停车场。去看电影这件事，对人们来说变得更加困难了，我认为，而替代方案则更容易接触到。但我们失去了某些东西。我认为，老式电影院就像是人们聚集的某种圣殿。那是一种社群联结。一周一次，或者一周两次，你会去看电影。
and parking lots. The thing of going to movies is it becomes more difficult, I think, for people, and the alternative's more easy to access. But we lose something. I think there's a, the old movie theaters were kinds of sort of temples where people would gather. It was a communal connection. Once a week you'd go to the movies, or twice a week.
在这种特殊的氛围中，它有一种精神上的共鸣。人们聚集在那里，某种程度上就像去教堂一样。镜框式舞台、美丽的剧院等等。我认为，所有这些之中有一种吸引人们的魔力，而我们现在没有那种东西了。即使是新建的剧院也少得多——当然它们是功利主义的——但在舞台构建等方面，想象力要少得多。
In this special atmosphere, it had a spiritual vibe to it. And people were collecting theirs, almost like going to church in a way. The proscenium, the beautiful theater and so on. And it was a magic in all of that, I think, that attracted people. And we don't have that anymore. Even in newly constructed theaters have far less – they're utilitarian, of course – but far less imagination in the way the stages are constructed and so on.
对。我想，反过来，我不知道这是否题外话，但我们想想三四百年前巴赫的音乐。当时没有音乐厅。如果你想听音乐，你必须去教堂听管风琴，听人们歌唱。那是你接受音乐的地方。你想听巴赫的康塔塔，你在教堂里听到它。
Right. I think, in turn, I don't know if this is off the subject, but we think of the music of Bach three or 400 years ago. There were no concert halls. If you wanted to hear music, you had to go to church to hear an organ, to hear people sing. And that's where you received your music. You wanted to hear Bach cantata, you heard it in church.
你不会在音乐厅里听到。音乐厅某种程度上是为了敲响古董钟声而建造的，你可以这么说，那是我们集体记忆的集合，为了非常非常特殊的事情而聚集在一起。我们在这种氛围中听贝多芬。或者我们在那种氛围中去看加里·格兰特和奥黛丽·赫本。太有趣了。
You didn't, not in the concert hall. The concert hall is in a way constructed to ring the antiquarian bells, I guess you could say, of our collective memory that were gathered for something very, very special. And we listen to Beethoven in this atmosphere. Or we go and we watch Cary Grant and Audrey Hepburn in that atmosphere. That's so interesting.
我认为所有的社会变化和这一切的实用主义方面已经发生了巨大的变化。我认为看电影体验中的那种精神层面在很大程度上已经消失了，这背后有一系列复杂的原因。是的。但我想。从技术的角度来看，你是否发现自己已经改变了，
I think all of the social changes and pragmatic aspects of all of this has changed so much. I think that spiritual aspect of the experience of seeing films is largely gone, a complex series of reasons for that. Yeah. But I think. From a technological perspective, have you found that you've changed,
想要改变、抗拒改变、不得不改变你思考配乐的方式？因为当人们在家里观看时，大多数情况下，他们并不处于最佳的音效环境中。很多人都在用立体声观看。有些人按下了他们电视上的环绕声按钮，但他们仍然没有获得他们在影院中获得的音频体验。
wanted to change, resisted change, had to change the way in which you think about your scores in that when people are watching at home, for the most part, they're not in the best sound environment possible. A lot of them are watching in stereo. Some have the sort of the surround button pressed on their television, but they're still,
你是否发现这会影响你对乐器平衡以及它们在声道中如何分布的思考？我想答案必须是否定的，因为当我在工作时，我想到的是某种我知道永远会存在下去的理想状态。这让我想说，还有其他不同之处。
they're not getting the kind of experience audio wise that they get in a theater. And do you find that that affects the way you think about creating a balance of instruments and where they would live in the channels? I think the answer has to be no, because when I'm working, I'm thinking of some kind of ideal that I know is ever gonna be there.
我认为可以实现的科技和特效使得弗雷德·阿斯泰尔那种长达 10 分钟、一镜头到底、复杂的舞蹈表演变得不再必要，而实际表演本身是令人惊叹的。我们不知道它是不是剪辑出来的，但我们可以感受到那种体能消耗的方面，
It makes me want to say, there are other differences. I think the technologies and special effects that can be accomplished make it unnecessary to do a 10-minute, one-take, complicated dance number by Fred Astaire, where the actual performance is something that is breathtaking. We don't know that it's not edited, but we can feel that aspect of physical exertion. something that is breathtaking. We don't know that it's not edited, but we can feel that aspect of physical exertion and mastery of one's body. The same can be said of orchestras, I think, also.
对身体的掌控。我想，交响乐团也是如此。很多精彩的音乐设计工作都是与管弦乐队结合完成的，这是一个绝妙的发展。然而，如果我们有一个四分钟长的场景，管弦乐队要在录音室里演奏，我们可能会为这四分钟的场景拍摄五个版本，每一个都不同。其中一个版本是充满活力的，其表演在精神上超越了其他所有四个版本。
The difference between so much beautiful work, by the way, of sound design is done in combination with orchestra. Now, a wonderful development. However, if we have a scene that's four minutes long and the orchestra's going to play that in the studio, we may make five takes of that four-minute scene and each one is different. One take is alive, is a performance that is above and beyond, spiritually all the other four.
你必须相信观众会对此做出反应。就像现场表演一样，你们都知道，每晚都不同。有些夜晚充满了魔力，而第二晚则平淡无奇。我们会说观众不好，或者无论我们怎么解释。
And you have to believe that the audience will respond to that. It's like live performances, as you all know, are different every night. Some night is full of magic, and the next night it's flat. We say the audience isn't good. and the next night it's flat. We say the audience isn't good. Or however we would explain it.
因此，我认为科技影响了电影的表演方面，使得很容易就能模拟出超出大多数人能力的事情。是的，这说得通。这就引出了我对你的创作过程的一个疑问。我曾在某处读到，你故意不读剧本，你第一次接触到这部电影
So I think technology has affected the performance aspect of film, making it very easy to sort of mock up something that is beyond most people's ability to do. Yeah, that makes sense. Which brings me to a question I have about your process. I read somewhere that you don't read the scripts on purpose and the first time that you're exposed to the film
就是剪辑好的粗剪版。当你在那里坐着看电影时，无论是《星球大战》、《侏罗纪公园》、《大白鲨》，还是别的什么，印第安纳·琼斯，你会不会，你是不是？继续说。我知道，这简直难以置信。当你看着它的时候，你是在脑海中构思一段旋律吗，然后那就是我们最终听到的旋律吗？
is the rough cut in the edit. And when you're sitting there watching the movie, whether it be Star Wars, Jurassic Park, Jaws, whatever it is, Indiana Jones, do you, are you? Keep going. I know, it's just unbelievable. Are you crafting a melody in your head as you're watching it, and then is that the melody
还是说这个过程对你来说是如何运作的？或者里面有暂用音乐（temp track）？是的，有暂用音乐吗？是的。如果可能的话，最好甚至不要读剧本或看任何东西，直到电影被剪辑好，那时我们可以形成第一印象，这将比几乎其他任何东西都更有效地引导我们的工作。
that we actually end up hearing? Or how does that process work for you? Or is there a temp in there? Yeah, is there a temp? Yeah. It is, it's good if possible not to even read a script or see Anything until the thing has been edited when we can form first impressions that will lead us in our work
你读了一本书，你为它选角，你发展了这种氛围等等，当你看到导演对这件事情的印象时，你可能会非常失望。或者也会感到高兴和惊讶。这并不总是可能的。也许在完成之前，我们必须与导演讨论某些事情。关于你的第二个问题，也许我可以称之为
More more effectively than almost anything else you read a book you you cast it you develop this the The atmosphere and so on and you can be very disappointed if you see a director's impression of what that would be. Or delighted and surprised also. It's not always possible. We have to discuss certain things with the directors maybe before it's been finished. And your second question about, maybe I can call it
主题灵感，如果你喜欢的话，那不是我一看到电影就能立刻想到的东西。在我的情况下，那是回到钢琴前，琢磨一两个或三个主题，把它们塑造成一种似乎不可避免的东西，就像它一直都在那里一样。是的，这太疯狂了。
thematic inspiration, if you like, that is not something I just pick up immediately when I see the film. In my case, it's going back to the panel, working a theme or two or three, manipulating them into something that seems inevitable, like it's been there always. Yeah, that's wild.
而那是工作中最难的部分。最简单的事情就是最难的事情。是的，话说当你在做《大白鲨》时，那个旋律是：E、F、E、F、E、F、E、F、E、F、E、F，斯皮尔伯格以为你在开玩笑，这是真的吗？这是真的吗？嗯，这是真的。我在想该怎么处理那条鲨鱼，
And that's the hardest part of the work. The simplest thing is the hardest thing. Yeah, and is it true that when you did Jaws, E, F, E, F, E, F, E, F, E, F, E, F, E, F, E, F, E, F, that Spielberg thought you were kidding, is that true? Is that true? Well, it is true. I wondered what to do about the shark,
但他走了进来，我弹奏了“咚，咚，咚，咚，咚，咚”。如果你还记得的话，第三个音符是一个D音。哦对，咚，咚，咚，咚。对，对。是的。他看着我说：“真的吗？你觉得这管用吗？”我当时想，我是不是疯了。我不大记得那段对话了，
but he came in and I played bum bum bum bum bum bum bum. There was a D in the third note, if you remember. Oh right, bum bum bum bum bum bum. Right, right. Yeah. And he looked at me and said, really? You think that could work? I thought maybe I had lost my mind. And I don't really remember the conversation,
但它一定类似于：“嗯，史蒂芬，我认为当大提琴、低音提琴和管弦乐队演奏时，它可以非常不祥。”它的好处在于它可以非常缓慢。“轰，轰，轰，轰，轰。”随着鲨鱼的逼近或障眼法的逼近，它可以加快速度。管弦乐队可以加入进来。
but it must have been something like, well, Steven, I think when the cellos and basses and the orchestra do it, it can be very ominous. And what is good about it is that it can be very slow. Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom. It can speed up as the shock is approaching or the red herring is approaching. And the orchestra can join.
如果需要的话，它可以震耳欲聋。法国号在那时切入，那是一个警报。叭-达-达-达！是的，完全正确。我们马上回来。本节目部分由 ZipRecruiter 赞助播出。我们许多人都听过亚伯拉罕·林肯的那句名言：“好饭不怕晚”，
It can be deafening if it needs to be. The horns come in there and that's an alert. Ba-da-da-da! Yeah, exactly. And we will be right back. We're brought to you in part by ZipRecruiter. Many of us have heard the famous quote by Abraham Lincoln that says, good things come to those who wait,
但这只是名言的一部分。我想，完整的话应该是：好饭不怕晚，但留下的只有努力争取的人。也许吧？好吧，如果你是一个企业主，想要团队里有最优秀的人才，同样的道理也适用。谢天谢地，ZipRecruiter 让你的招聘充满干劲，让你快速找到符合要求的候选人。
but that's only part of the quote. The full quote, I think, is, good things come to those who wait. But that's only part of the quote. The full quote, I think, is good things come to those who wait, but only the things left by those who hustle. Maybe? Well, if you're a business owner and want the best people on your team, the same applies. Thankfully, ZipRecruiter puts the hustle in your hiring, so you find qualified candidates fast.
现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com slash smartList 上免费试用它。如果你碰巧看到一个非常适合你岗位的候选人，ZipRecruiter 可以帮你确保你处于最显眼的位置。你只需要使用 ZipRecruiter 的预写邀请申请消息，即可尽快与你中意的人选取得联系。就是这么简单。让 ZipRecruiter 赋予你所需的招聘动力。
And now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartList. If you happen to see a candidate who'd be perfect for your role, ZipRecruiter can help make sure you're front and center. All you need to do is use ZipRecruiter's pre-written invite to apply message to connect with your favorite's ASAP. It's that easy. Let ZipRecruiter give you the hiring hustle you need.
来看看为什么五分之四在 ZipRecruiter 上发布招聘信息的雇主在第一天内就能找到合适的候选人。只需前往 ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist 即可免费试用。再次提醒，网址是 ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，今年过得太快了。我是说，我感到自豪的是，到目前为止，我觉得自己今年在当朋友、父亲或丈夫方面稍微做得更好了一点。
See why four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlis to try it for free. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, this year's gone so quickly. I mean, I'm proud so far that I am, I think I'm slightly better at being a friend or father or husband this year.
我每年都在努力把这些事情做好，但你知道，如果你稍微有点欠缺，或者你觉得自己有点欠缺，我是说，BetterHelp 会是一个好主意。我的意思是，当生活过得如此之快时，花点时间庆祝你的胜利并对余下的年份做出调整是很重要的。心理咨询可以帮你盘点你的进展，并为接下来的六个月设定可实现的目标。如果你正在考虑开始
I've been trying every year to be better at that stuff, but you know, if you're coming up a little short or you think you're coming up a little short, I mean, better help would be a great idea. I mean, when life goes so fast, it is important to take a moment to celebrate your wins and make adjustments for the rest of the year. Therapy can help you take stock of your progress and set achievable goals for the next six months. If you're thinking about starting
心理咨询，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在线上进行，旨在提供便利、灵活的服务，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。花点时间。今天就访问 betterhelp.com slash smartless，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是 betterhelp.com slash smartless。Smartless 的听众朋友们，让我向你们介绍一下卫士 110 (Defender 110)。对于那些拥抱不可能的人来说，卫士 110 已经准备好迎接冒险了。这款标志性的车型经过重新定义，
therapy, give Better Help a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Take a moment. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.com slash smartless. Smartless listener, let me tell you about the Defender 110. For those who embrace the impossible, the Defender 110 is up for the adventure. This iconic vehicle has been redefined
采用了完全现代的设计。外观比例迷人，内饰则采用坚固的材料和精湛的工艺打造。卫士的性能堪称传奇。无论你面对的是越野挑战还是恶劣的天气条件，你都可以依靠他们创新的摄像机技术来提供开阔的视野和轻松的操控。我觉得它看起来超级流线型。我觉得它很现代。
with thoroughly modern design. The exterior offers compelling proportions while the interior has been built with robust materials and integrity. The Defender's capability is legendary. Whether you're facing off-road challenges or harsh weather conditions, you can rely on their innovative camera technologies to deliver unobstructed views and effortless maneuvering. I think it's super slick looking. I think it's modern.
它专为任何公路旅行而打造。对于长途旅行来说，它很耐用。它有点像全能、万能的汽车，有了它，人们就不需要别的什么车了。卫士系列随时准备迎接各种冒险，拥有双门卫士 90、卫士 110 以及可容纳多达八人的卫士 130。欲了解更多信息，请访问 landroverusa.com 附带 slash Defender。现在回到节目中。你知道，有趣的是你这么说，当你，
It's built for any road trip. It's durable for big trips. It's kind of like the all-in-one, all-purpose car that nobody needs anything else for. Ready for a wide range of adventures, the Defender family features the two-door Defender 90, the Defender 110, and the Defender 130, which seats up to eight. Learn more at landriverusa.com forward slash Defender. And now back to the show. You know, it's interesting you say that when you,
你向史蒂芬提出了那个方案，然后也许他有点犹豫，或者他以为你在开玩笑。你是否注意到，或者这些年来你有没有注意到？因为在电影上工作是一种高度合作的体验，当你与导演合作时，你有没有注意到，也许他们一开始并没有像你那样对音乐有那么高的欣赏水平，而他们已经学会了，或者某些导演已经学会了——事实上，这些年来你一直在教育他们——他们对音乐的感受力、
that you sort of pitched that to Steve and then he maybe he's a little reluctant or he thinks that you're kidding. Do you notice or when you that you sort of pitch that to Steve and and then he maybe is a little reluctant Or he thinks that you're kidding. Do you notice or have you noticed over the years? Because it's such a collaborative Experience working on a film and when you're working with the director Have you noticed that maybe they didn't start with they didn't have such an appreciation of music in the same way that you do And that they've learned or have certain directors learn to become, that you've in fact educated them over the years, and that their sense of,
他们在接触音乐时的成熟度变得好多了？抱歉，这是一个措辞不当的问题，但在与史蒂芬合作多年后，你有没有注意到他欣赏你工作能力的方式变得更加……合作性了。
their sophistication when it comes to approaching music has gotten much better. Sorry, this is a poorly worded question, but after working for years with Steven, have you noticed that his ability to appreciate what you're doing has gotten more... Collaborative.
对，而且更成熟了。更成熟了。对。这很难，因为这些导演的训练以及他们培养或未培养出的品味有很大的差异，他们的教育水平各不相同，角度也各不相同，等等。如果你谈论巴托克的《小提琴协奏曲》或类似的作品，他们大多数人不知道那是什么。
Yeah, and sophisticated. And sophisticated. Yeah. It's tough because there's so much variation in the training of these directors and the taste that they develop or don't develop and their educations are all at a different level and from different angles and so on. If you talk about a Bartok Violin Concerto or something, most of them will not know what that is.
对。大多数电影导演会了解、熟悉一些电影音乐。他们会知道伯纳德·赫尔曼，会知道米克罗斯·罗萨等等。但他们不会知道利盖蒂，甚至不知道比这更冷门的东西。我不知道你们是否还记得马丁·里特，一位在纽约当过戏剧导演的导演，像卡赞一样来到这里，拍了一些很棒的电影。他对电影中的音乐非常怀疑。他来自百老汇，在那里我们没有背景音乐，或者很少有背景音乐，他希望人们相信
Right. Most film directors will know, have some familiarity with film music. They will know Bernard Herrmann and they will know Miklas Rosia and so on and so forth. But they won't know Ligeti or even less esoteric things than that. I don't know if you all remember Martin Ritt, a director who was a theater director in New York, came out here like Kazan and did some wonderful films. Was very suspicious of music in his film. He'd come from Broadway where we didn't have background music or rarely had it, and he wanted people to believe
他们所看到的和所听到的是真实的。所以你把一个交响乐团放在这个对话场景后面，像马丁·鲁特这样的人就会说：“我无法相信。我不需要那个。我已经创造了这个场景。我的演员已经完成了工作。你不需要帮他们。”
what they were seeing and what they were hearing was real. And so you have put a symphony orchestra behind this dialogue scene and they say, man like Martin Rue says, I can't believe that. I don't need to have that. I've created the scene. My actors have done the job. You don't need to help them.
这与史蒂芬相反，史蒂芬似乎在他的电影里怎么也塞不够音乐。不过这对我来说不同，对我很好。是的，对，对，对。对我来说是好搭档。他，说下去，抱歉。这里面有很大的差异，但我认为人们真正认识到的是，
And that's the opposite of Steven, who can't seem to quite get enough music in his film. Different, good for me, by the way. Yeah, right, right, right. Partner for me. Was he, go ahead, sorry. There's such variation there, but I think what people truly recognize
伯纳德·赫尔曼的话是对的。没有所谓的无声电影。我们回溯到过去，当有声片出现时，我们有管风琴，或者我们在乐池里有一个管弦乐队，我们有人拉小提琴，做一些能让画面生动起来的事情。音乐似乎是电影制作中不可分割的一部分。无论是当代的电子音乐
is that it's true what Bernard Harmon said. There's no such thing as a silent film. We go back when the silence, we had the silence, we had organ or we had an orchestra in the pit, we had somebody playing a violin, something that would animate. And music seems an inseparable part of filmmaking. And whether it's contemporary electronic music
还是古典的浪漫主义音乐，我们都认识到它的需求。有时，当你为演员播放太多音乐时，他们会非常不高兴。是的，是的。你们俩在《辛德勒的名单》中经历的音调转变和电影制作转变，对他来说，过渡到一种由设计决定的、我确信更加精简的方法，并且更具潜在的，我不知道“成熟”是不是正确的词，但这绝对背离了你们长期以来一直在做的事情，那对你们来说是令人兴奋的，还是对他来说有点吓人？你是说资源和《辛德勒》中，更多的室内乐，规模更小。
or classical romantic music, we recognize the need of it. Actors will be sometimes very unhappy when you play too much music for them. Yeah, yeah. Was the tonal shift and filmmaking shift that you both went through on Schindler's List, was that a comfortable transition for him into what was a much more pared down approach
对，是的。是的，有时候单一乐器少了很多，而不是更饱满的管弦乐。有些场景就像帕尔曼一个人。一些最惊人、最可怕的时刻只是他的小提琴。无论是为了使其成为一种更私密的室内乐而做出的有意识的决定，
by design, I'm sure, and much more potentially, I don't know, sophisticated is the right word, but it was definitely a departure from what you guys had been doing for so long. Was that exciting to you guys or a little scary for him, maybe? You mean the resources and shindles, more chamber music was a smaller.
还是我们通过潜意识或对话做出的决定，我都记不清了。我猜类似于哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒这样的东西在一般情况下是行不通的。我不认为那是六把小号在全力吹奏。我不认为那样效果会很好。对，对。
Right, yeah. Yeah, a lot less single instruments at times as opposed to a more full-bodied orchestral. Some of the scenes were it's like Prillman alone. Some of the most breathtaking and horrible things was just his file. Whether it was a conscious decision to make it a more intimate chamber music kind of thing
所以我们坚持用帕尔曼的演奏，但这是一个好得多的主意。你知道，你刚才提到现场表演的魔力，以及观众无法真正享受这一点是多么遗憾，因为由于配乐的制作过程，他们无法完全信任它。
was something we must have made unconsciously or through dialogue, I don't remember. I'm guessing something like, da da da da da da da da da da da da wouldn't work in general. I don't think it was six trumpets blowing their brains out. I don't think it would work quite well. Right, right.
但在洛杉矶，我发现的最伟大的文化活动之一——大家都承认这样的活动并不多——就是在好莱坞碗形剧场，当他们在巨幕上播放电影，剥离所有音乐，让洛杉矶爱乐乐团现场演奏时，通常你会去指挥。所以对于特雷西来说，就像你听到的所有音乐一样，
So we stay with this up, Perlman, but a much better idea. You know, you mentioned earlier that the magic of a live performance and what a shame it is that the audience can't truly enjoy that because they can't fully trust it because of the process of putting together a score.
以《大白鲨》为例，如果你把所有的音乐都剥离掉，只看带有所有对白和音效的电影，那是另一回事，但音乐是任何约翰·威廉姆斯电影中一个巨大的角色。所以他们把所有的音乐都剥离出来，然后用整个——
But one of the greatest cultural things I find in Los Angeles, of which there aren't many, I think everybody admits, is at the Hollywood Bowl, when they run a movie on the big screen and they pull all the music out and they have the LA Phil do it, and oftentimes you'll conduct that. But so for Tracy, like all the music you hear,
对，跟拍画面，是的。是的，整个交响乐团或整个管弦乐队。你喜欢这样做吗？对我来说，这简直是魔力，因为它是现场表演。你看到它被完美地完成，与画面完美契合。是的，感觉就像如果你错失了一个节拍。嗯，这也是一种能量，对吧？
and take Jaws for example, if you pulled all the music out of it and you just watched the movie with all the dialogue and sound effects, that's something, but the music is an enormous character in any John Williams film. And so they just pull all that music out and then they play it live with the entire-
对，简直太惊艳了。我喜欢它。我喜欢这样做，是的，这很有趣。我也喜欢不这样做。意思是说，我可以在剧院或碗形剧场为观众演奏配乐，没有电影，没有电影的干扰。我可以向观众描述，
Right, shoot the picture, yeah. Yeah, the entire symphony or the entire orchestra. Do you like doing that? I mean, for me, it's magic because it is that live performance. You're seeing it done, pristine, matched to picture. Yeah, and it feels like if you miss one beat. Well, there's energy too, right?
他们即将听到的是他们在动作场景等中会听到的那种炫技，那里的音乐极难演奏。那是炫技级别的，当你看电影时，你是无法体会到这一点的。干扰太多了。对，是的，没错。无论是带电影还是不带电影，我都非常乐意接受。等等，说到难以演奏的东西。我们可能不得不剪掉这段，但我试着演奏《E.T.外星人》片尾曲的音乐，但你找不到，它没有在任何地方出版。
Yeah, it's just stunning. I love it. I like doing it, yes, it is fun. I also like not doing it. Meaning I can play the score for the audience in the theater or at the bowl without the film, without the distraction of the film. And I can describe to the audience,
所以我的丈夫斯科蒂在互联网上搜寻，我们终于找到了。这是我演奏结尾部分，这是我最喜欢的曲子之一，
they're about to hear the kind of virtuosity they're going to hear in action scenes and so on, where the music is extremely difficult to play. It's at a virtuoso level, which when you watch the film, you can't appreciate it. There's just too much distraction. Right, yeah, that's right. I can take it very happily both ways,
这太难了，因为你写的音乐非常难。 ["The End of the World"] 太疯狂了。这确实很难，是的。这太疯狂了，而且没完没了。肖恩，这真的很棒。肖恩，你把我震惊了。
with film or without it. Wait, talk about things that are difficult to play. We might have to cut this, but I try to get the end credits music to ET, and you can't find it, it's not published anywhere. And so my husband, Scotty, scoured the internet, we finally got it. This is me playing the end, which is one of my favorite pieces,
稍微有点快，我刚才稍微慢了一点。我觉得你把它写得很慢，我觉得你把它写得很慢。确实有点快。肖恩，接受这个意见，好吗？稍微慢了一点。我觉得你把它写得很慢。我觉得你把它写得很慢。确实有点快。肖恩，接受这个意见，好吗？稍微快了一点。接受约翰·威廉姆斯的意见。但现在给人们讲讲《E.T.外星人》最后 15 分钟的故事，因为那太迷人了。
and it's so hard hard because you write very difficult music. ["The End of the World"] It's crazy. It is difficult, yeah. It's insane and it goes on and on. Sean, that's really good. Sean, you knocked me out.
刚才你提到史蒂芬非常喜欢电影里有大量音乐。是的。那么《E.T.外星人》最后 15 分钟发生了什么？嗯，你记得最后 15 分钟是以自行车追逐开始的。警察追捕孩子们，孩子们试图把 E.T. 送回他的飞船。
It's a little fast, I was just a little bit slow. I think you wrote it slow, I think you wrote it slow. It is a little fast. Sean, take the note, okay? A little bit slow. I think you wrote it slow. I think you wrote it slow. It is a little fast. Sean, take the note, okay? A little fast. Take the note from John Williams. But now tell people the story of the last 15 minutes of ET because that's fascinating.
他们加速到逃逸速度，据我所知，那是每小时 17,500 英里。我们接受了这个设定，所以孩子们飞越了月亮。顺便说一句，这个细节我是从 NASA 那里了解到的。你骑自行车必须以多快的速度行驶才能飞越月亮？17,500 英里。他们降落了，飞船降落了，E.T. 和他的小伙伴们，地球上的孩子们，
Just a moment ago you said Stephen really loves a lot of music in his movies. Yes. So what happened in the last 15 minutes of ET? Well, you remember the last 15 minutes had started with the bike chase. The police chasing the kids, the kids trying to get ET back to his spaceship.
向 E.T. 道别，非常感人。在这一段落的结束时，飞船将升空，伴随着那一刻小号的华彩乐段等，向左盘旋。所以在那 10 分钟里，大概在 10 分钟的每一分钟里，可能有 10 个同步点，对吧？也许更多，某人的脚，自行车的上升，
And they accelerate to escape velocity, which I understand is 17,500 miles an hour. And we buy that, so the kids fly over the moon. I've got that detail from NASA, by the way. How fast do you have to go on a bike to go over the moon? 17,500 miles. And they land, and the spaceship lands, and ET and his little friends, earthling children,
某物落下，诸如此类。几乎就像一部动画片，但你不想以那种方式去听，不过你希望支持，至少在这一段、这部电影的风格中是这样。所以在录音那天，我让管弦乐队排练了一段曲子，录了几个版本，我可以完成前两分钟，我们可以把这两分钟分开来做。
say goodbye to Etienne, it's very sentimental. And at the end of the sequence, the ship will go up and does a whirling left turn to the flourishes of trumpets at that moment and so on. So in that 10 minutes, there's probably, in every minute of the 10, there are probably 10 sink points, okay? Maybe more, somebody's foot, bicycle going up,
我在第四分钟遇到了一些问题，同步问题，管弦乐队不想像电影所允许的那样绽放得更多一点。或者一些集中的动作电影加速了，再加速，然后到达这里，所以比我希望管弦乐队跟上的速度要快一点。我真的无法达到应有的同步。
something falling, whatever. Almost like a cartoon, but you don't want to hear it that way, but you want to support, at least in the style of this thing, this film. So on the day of recording, I had the orchestra and we rehearsed a piece and made a few takes and I could accomplish the first two minutes, which we could have done separately.
我最终对史蒂芬说：“我好像无法把这个弄对。”他说：“我们把电影关掉。我们知道同步点在哪里。音乐就是为那个结局构建的。”你录制音乐，其中所有的自由速度（rubati）、乐句等等都是为了音乐的满足感、整个事情的呼吸感而完成的。他提出要重新剪辑电影？
And I had problems in four, sinking, not the orchestra wanted to bloom out or blossom out a little bit more than the film would allow me to do. Or some concentrated action film that sped up and sped up and arrived here, so a little quicker than I wanted to get the orchestra to it. And I really couldn't get the sync the way it should be.
他说：“我将只为音轨重新剪辑电影。”配合你的音乐。这就是他做的。这太疯狂了。我真的相信有一种，这不是拉比在抬高自己，那最后 10 分钟有某种歌剧般的特质。是的。
And I finally said to Steven, I can't seem to be able to get this right, he said, we'll turn the film off. We know where the sink points are. The music is constructed for that end. And you record the music where all the rubati, the phrasing and so on, is done for musical satisfaction, the breathing of the whole thing. And he offered to recut the film?
我认为如果没有整个管弦乐队那种收放自如的呼吸，他们想要的方式，以及两者在这里结束而不是在那里结束，这种如果你愿意的话可以说是动力的东西，比死板地同步的版本更令人满意……似乎比那种死板同步的版本更令人满意。对。是的。天哪。
And he said, I will just recut the film for the track. To your music. Which is what he did. Which is crazy. And I really believe that there's a kind of a, this is not a rabbi placing himself, there's something operatic about that last 10 minutes. Yeah.
我喜欢这种对音乐的要求，音乐要求电影必须根据它来进行剪辑。我的意思是，这展现了音乐的力量。有没有哪部电影或哪个项目，你刚接触时觉得，是的，这会很棒，然后你意识到你被它吓到了，或者你觉得，你刚刚举了个例子
That I think without that give and take breathing of the whole orchestra, the way they wanted to, and the way the both finish here but not here, this kind of kinetic, if you like, is more satisfa... seems to be more satisfactory than a take that is slavishly in sync. Right. Yes. Yeah. Gosh.
我认为，如果没有整个乐团那种互动的、有呼吸感的演奏，没有他们想要的、有时这里同步有时那里不同步的这种动感，这种感觉，如果你喜欢的话，似乎比那种死板同步的录音要更令人满意……是的。对啊。天哪。
I love that that demanded it, that that music demanded that the film be cut to it. I mean, it shows the power of the music. Has there ever been a film or a project that you've come into and you've thought, yeah, this is gonna be great, and then you realize that you were intimidated by it or you thought, you just gave an example
我喜欢这种要求，音乐要求电影必须根据它来剪辑。我的意思是，这展现了音乐的力量。有没有哪个电影或项目是你一开始觉得“太棒了”，然后才意识到你其实对它感到畏惧，或者你刚才举过一个例子
of a difficult situation you were in, but was there ever something that you thought, you just gave an example of a difficult situation you were in, but was there ever something that you thought like, I don't know if I have, I don't know if I can do this, particularly. The right fight for it. If I can match the power of what's on the screen with the right music. Have you ever been intimidated in that way?
你身处困境的例子，但你有没有想过——你刚举了一个你身处困境的例子——但你有没有过那种想法，比如，我不知道我有没有，我不知道我能不能做到这一点，尤其是为它找到正确的配乐。如果我能用合适的音乐去匹配银幕上展现的力量。你曾为此感到过畏惧吗？
He's like, no, look at me. Yes. Every film. Oh really, really? Is intimidating that way? He's like, no, look at me. Yes. Every film. Oh really, really? Is it doing that way? I could say glibly. But to reduce it a little bit, I would say The Close Encounters was,
他说，不，看着我。是的。每一部电影。哦，真的吗，真的吗？那种方式让人畏惧？他说，不，看着我。是的。每一部电影。哦，真的吗，真的吗？真的是那样吗？我可以轻率地说。但稍微简化一下，我会说《第三类接触》是，
I had that kind of feeling about it. Right of extraordinary. Somehow something about that grammar. I think it was 1977, and I had done first Star Wars and Close Encounters the same year. And it was, talk about a head turn thing, I had really struggled to get out of Star Wars and into Close Encounters.
我对它有那种感觉。没错，非凡的。不知为何，那部作品的某种语感。我想那是1977年，同一年我完成了第一部《星球大战》和《第三类接触》。那真是，说到让人脑回路急转弯的事，我当时真的很挣扎，才从《星球大战》过渡到《第三类接触》。
Talk about spiritual aspects of, I mean the whole end of that film took us to a place, a high place, and the orchestra had to, it almost has a religious quality to it. Yeah, for sure. And where Star Wars is all fun and fanfare is an action and comedy and all the rest of that, but this was a more serious thought about our circumstance in the universe,
说到其中的精神层面，我是说那部电影的结尾把我们带到了一个地方，一个崇高的境界，管弦乐队不得不这样做，它几乎带有一种宗教般的特质。是的，肯定的。《星球大战》充满乐趣、号角齐鸣、动作和喜剧以及其他种种，但这部电影是对我们在宇宙中的处境、
where we are and where we may be going. It deeply affected me as a young boy. Me too, it was the first film that, you know, I was young when it came out, but I saw it, and I've seen it so many times over the years, it's one of the only films that I will re-watch consistently. And it did have that, it's funny you say that. That one and the first Teletubbies, right?
我们身在何处以及我们要去向何方的更严肃的思考。它作为小男孩的我深深震撼了。我也是，它是我看的第一部……你知道，它上映时我还很小，但我看了，这些年来我看了无数次，它是为数不多我会一直反复观看的电影之一。而且它确实有那种感觉，你这么说真有趣。那部和第一季《天线宝宝》，对吧？
And Teletubbies, obviously. And also your score for the Gilligan's Island pilot. Yes. People don't know that you wrote, that's true actually. That's a true story, JB. That was really hard. John, what portion of that iconic dun dun dun dun dun was scripted, What portion of that iconic,
还有《天线宝宝》，显而易见。还有你为《吉利甘岛》试播集创作的配乐。是的。人们不知道你写过，其实那是真的。那是真的故事，JB。那真的很难。约翰，那个标志性的“咚 咚 咚 咚 咚”有多少是剧本写好的？那个标志性的，
dun dun dun dun dun, was scripted? And what portion of it was open to your autonomy? It's sort of like, how was that described in the script? Where did the script stop and where did you pick up? And do you remember the moment that you came up with those notes? I think the script asked for five notes, I believe. And at my first sort of attempts at that, I kept saying to Stephen, it's much easier to do seven.
“咚 咚 咚 咚 咚”，有多少是剧本规定的？又有多少是由你自主发挥的？这有点像，剧本里是怎么描述的？剧本在哪里停下，你又在哪里接手？你还记得你想出那些音符时的那一刻吗？我想剧本要求五个音符，我相信是的。在我最初的几次尝试中，我一直对斯蒂芬说，做七个音符要容易得多。
But seven, five is like a doorbell, it's like a signal. Where seven notes, you just get over that thump and now you've got, when you wish upon a star, if you like, I don't know how many notes that is in the phrase, but it becomes a melody rather than a signal. So in six and seven were those big heavy, bom bom. Yes, right.
但七个音符……五个音符就像门铃，就像一个信号。而七个音符，你刚跨过那个坎，现在你有了……如果你喜欢的话，就像《当你向星星许愿》一样，我不知道那个乐句里有多少个音符，但它成了一个旋律，而不是一个信号。所以在第六和第七个音符里有那些沉重的“咚，咚”。是的，对吧。
No, no, four and five. Break the glass. One, two, three, four, five. Bom bom. And then there was. Oh, da da da. That was a response. That was the response, yeah. Oh, that was such a language.
不，不，第四和第五个。打破玻璃。一，二，三，四，五。“咚咚”。然后还有。哦，“哒哒哒”。那是回应。那是回应，是的。哦，那是多么美妙的一种语言。
So then I took some paper, I still have the papers, and I think I wrote about, I don't know, 100 or more five note motifs in any intervallic relationship, up, down, so to speak, and no consideration of length of the notes. It isn't da-bi-bum, bum-bum. It doesn't do that.
于是我拿了一些纸，我到现在还留着这些纸，我想我大概写了……我不知道，100个或更多五音符的动机，采用各种音程关系，上下起伏，可以说是这样，而且没有考虑音符的长度。它不是“哒-比-本，本-本”。它不是那样的。
And I kept playing them for Steve and he would come over my piano and we'd go through these things. And we both kept circling this one without deciding and finally one day in frustration, we weren't getting anywhere and he said or I said, let's just use this one, it seems fine. Yeah, fine. It seems fine. But it was scripted that the strategy of the scientists
我一直把它们弹给斯蒂夫听，他会走到我的钢琴旁，我们把这些东西过了一遍。我们俩一直在这个音符周围打转，却迟迟拿不定主意，最后有一天在沮丧中，我们毫无进展，他说或者我说，我们就用这个吧，看起来挺好的。对，挺好的。看起来挺好的。但剧本里确实写了，科学家们的策略是
were to communicate with the ship via five musical notes, sound. Yeah, so that must have been enormously. Intimidating. Intimidating, right? Because you're like, it's not score, it's actually language that they've written into this script and I gotta come up with what the language is.
通过五个音符的声音与飞船进行交流。是的，所以那一定非常……令人畏惧。令人畏惧，对吧？因为你会觉得，这不是配乐，这实际上是他们写进剧本里的语言，而我得想出这门语言是什么。
That's right. Wow. That's true. Well, there's a lot of the conversation that we now know back and forth between this computer, Truffaut and his group and the ship's answers, was much more elaborate with color and lights. Stephen eventually correctly cut it down a little bit so it was meant more manageable. But it's a wonderful idea. I mean, there are, like Kodály, who was a Hungarian composer,
没准。哇。确实如此。嗯，我们现在知道的很多来回对话，在这台电脑、特吕弗和他的团队与飞船的回答之间，原本要复杂得多，带有颜色和灯光。斯蒂芬最终正确地将其稍微删减了一下，使其更便于掌控。但这是一个绝妙的想法。我是说，有像柯达伊（一位匈牙利作曲家），
with this idea of hand signals that's almost like deaf people would hear notes. And Skriyabin, a Russian composer, who was obsessed with the idea of color, and red is a certain kind of note, or a certain texture texture and so on. So a lot of work had been done and not really very scientific work at all.
他提出了手势信号的想法，几乎就像聋人能听到音符一样。还有斯克里亚宾（一位俄罗斯作曲家），他痴迷于色彩的概念，红色对应某种音符，或者某种质感，等等。所以当时已经做了很多工作，而且并不是真正非常科学的工作。
It was so primary. It was like how you would maybe elect to communicate with a child that doesn't yet know language. That's what was so powerful and evergreen and universal about it. And then when the conversation gets going and they're getting into a conversation, I mean, John, that was just magic.
它是那么基础。就像你可能会选择与一个还不懂语言的孩子交流的方式。这就是它如此强大、历久弥新且具有普遍性的原因。然后当对话开始并且他们进入状态时，我是说，约翰，那简直太神奇了。
How you just made that all blossom and it just became like a celebration and they all got all carried away. It's just incredible. It was all written out. I have it so on and put into a computer to produce it. But John, it's truly what Jason says is, and again, I'm sort of going back
你让这一切绽放开来，它变得就像一场庆祝活动，所有人都陶醉其中。这简直不可思议。这些全都是写好的。我把它记下来并输入电脑来制作它。但是约翰，贾森说的话确实是……而且再次声明，我有点回到过去，
and doubling down on this, but the idea that Jay and Sean too, that we as young men, we were still single digits, I was about eight when that, seven or eight when I came out, but I understood that in a way that was meant to be understood, in a way that my parents could, I could understand it emotionally.
并在这一点上加倍强调，但杰伊和肖恩也是这么认为的，我们作为小男孩时，我们还不到十岁，当那部电影上映时我大约八岁，七、八岁吧，但我以一种本来就该被理解的方式理解了它，以一种我的父母能……我能从情感上理解的方式。
What was going on? Leaving the theater with my mom in the parking lot, I said to her, I wanna be taken. And I was serious. She said, we wanted you to and they gave you back. Yeah. They wouldn't take you. I really turned.
到底发生了什么？在停车场和妈妈离开电影院时，我对她说，我想被带走。我是认真的。她说，我们希望他们带走你，然后他们把你送回来了。是的。他们才不会带走你呢。我真的转变了。
He told me that's a friend. One thing I would say at this point is that it's probably true that music is older than language and that's deeply embedded in all of our structure and you understood it not linguistically but musically or spiritually in some way. Yeah. Yeah. We'll be right back.
他告诉我那是朋友。我要在此时说的一件事是，音乐可能比语言更古老，这一点深深地嵌入了我们所有人的结构中，你理解它不是通过语言，而是通过某种音乐或精神上的方式。是的。是的。我们马上回来。
This episode is sponsored in part by Liquid Death. You may have spotted your designated driver downing a tall can, but after taking a second look, you see that it's actually a can of Liquid Death. Liquid Death may look like some type of energy drink or beer, but instead it is a line of crisp, low sugar sodas, low sugar iced teas, and refreshing mountain spring water. But why the name Liquid Death?
本集部分内容由 Liquid Death 赞助播出。你可能曾发现你的指定代驾在狂灌一大罐饮料，但仔细一看，你会发现那其实是一罐 Liquid Death。Liquid Death 看起来可能像某种能量饮料或啤酒，但它实际上是一系列清爽、低糖的苏打水、低糖冰茶和清爽的山泉水。但为什么要叫 Liquid Death（液体死亡）呢？
They're here to crush the use of single-use plastic bottles with their recyclable cans. I love the way I look chugging Liquid Death. I like the way it makes me feel chugging a whole liquid death mountain spring water. It makes me feel tough. And I don't care what people think I'm drinking. I'm drinking Liquid Death Water. I know it's good for me and I know it's Mountain Water. And I drink one in the car, I drink one on the go,
他们通过可回收的罐子来坚决抵制一次性塑料瓶的使用。我喜欢我狂灌 Liquid Death 时的样子。我喜欢那种狂灌整罐 Liquid Death 山泉水的感觉。这让我觉得自己很硬汉。而且我不在乎别人觉得我在喝什么。我在喝 Liquid Death 水。我知道这对我有好处，我也知道这是山泉水。我在车里喝一罐，在路上喝一罐，
it just makes me feel great. Like I'm gonna live forever with Liquid Death. You can get free shipping of Liquid Death's Mountain Water Flavored Sparkling and Ice Tea, eight packs with Amazon Prime, or grab a can or a case at your local 7-Eleven, Target, Walmart, Whole Foods, or on Instacart. Go to liquiddeath.com slash smartlis to check out all their healthy,
这让我感觉棒极了。就像我要和 Liquid Death 一起活到永远一样。你可以在亚马逊 Prime 上享受 Liquid Death 山泉水风味气泡茶和冰茶八连包的免费配送，也可以在当地的 7-Eleven、Target、Walmart、Whole Foods 或 Instacart 上购买单罐或整箱。访问 liquiddeath.com 斜杠 smartlis 去查看他们所有健康、
infinitely recyclable beverages and find your closest retailer. That's liquiddeath.com slash smartlis. Liquiddeath.com slash smartlis. Smartlis gets support from GoodRx. Summer is in full swing, and we're all looking for ways to save money Smartless. All you need to do is search for your prescription on the GoodRx website or app and show your discount at the pharmacy. With GoodRx, you can find prescription savings at the pharmacies right in your neighborhood, including CVS, Walgreens, Walmart, Vons, Sam's Club, Publix, and more. And remember, GoodRx works whether you have insurance or not. Even if you have insurance, GoodRx could beat your copay price. So, with your filling prescriptions this summer, don't forget to check GoodRx before you get to the pharmacy. For simple, smart savings on your prescriptions, check GoodRx.
可无限回收的饮品，并找到离你最近的零售商。网址是 liquiddeath.com 斜杠 smartlis。liquiddeath.com 斜杠 smartlis。Smartless 获得 GoodRx 的支持。夏天正如火如荼地进行着，我们都在寻找省钱的方法，Smartless。你所需要做的就是在 GoodRx 网站或应用上搜索你的处方，并在药房出示你的折扣。通过 GoodRx，你可以在家附近的药房找到处方优惠，包括 CVS、Walgreens、Walmart、Vons、Sam's Club、Publix 等等。请记住，无论你有没有保险，GoodRx 都适用。即使你有保险，GoodRx 的价格也可能比你的共付额更便宜。所以，今年夏天你在抓药时，别忘了在去药房前先查一下 GoodRx。想要在处方药上获得简单、聪明的省钱方式，请查看 GoodRx。
Go to GoodRx.com slash SmartList. That's GoodRx.com slash SmartList. SmartList is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your imagination soar. Whether you listen to stories, motivation, expert advice, any genre you love, you can be inspired to imagine new worlds, new possibilities, new ways of thinking. Find the genres you love and discover new ones
访问 GoodRx.com 斜杠 SmartList。网址是 GoodRx.com 斜杠 SmartList。SmartList 部分内容由 Audible 带给您。在 Audible 上聆听能让您的想象力尽情翱翔。无论您是听故事、励志内容、专家建议，还是您喜爱的任何流派，您都能获得启发，去想象新的世界、新的可能性、新的思维方式。寻找您喜爱的流派，并在旅途中发现新的流派。
along the way. Explore bestsellers, new releases, plus thousands of included audiobooks, podcasts, and originals that members can listen to all they want with more added all the time. Audible makes it easy to be inspired and entertained as part of your daily routine without needing to set all the time. Audible makes it easy to be inspired and entertained as part of your daily routine without needing to set aside extra time.
探索畅销书、新书上架，以及数千部会员可以无限畅听的包含有声书、播客和原创作品，并且不断有新内容加入。Audible 让您无需刻意腾出额外时间，就能轻轻松松在日常生活中获得灵感与娱乐。Audible 让您无需刻意腾出额外时间，就能轻轻松松在日常生活中获得灵感与娱乐。
There's more to imagine when you listen. I just listened to Never Lie by Frieda McFadden. Oh boy, is that a good story. It's so good. I was so shocked. I actually, I had my earbuds in listening to it and I gasped audibly, no pun intended. At this one point and Scottie looked at me
聆听时，会有更多想象空间。我刚听完弗里达·麦克法登的《永不撒谎》。天哪，那真是一个好故事。太精彩了。我太震惊了。实际上，我塞着耳塞在听，我情不自禁地倒吸了一口气，双关语可不是这个意思。在某个时刻，斯科蒂看着我，
and was like, what's your problem? I'm like, there's a twist in that story that is so gasp-worthy. Did not see it coming. And the whole time I'm like, oh, I got this story guessed. I did not have it guessed at all. It's really, really exciting. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month
问我怎么了。我说，那个故事里的反转太让人倒吸一口凉气了。完全没猜到。而且整个过程我都觉得，哦，这个故事我猜到了。我根本一点都没猜到。真的非常非常精彩。作为 Audible 会员，你每个月可以从整个目录中选择一本作品
to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 to try Audible free for 30 days.
永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书。新会员可以免费试用 Audible 30 天。访问 audible.com 斜杠 smartless，或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500。网址是 audible.com 斜杠 smartless，或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500，即可免费试用 Audible 30 天。
Audible.com slash smartless. Smartless is brought to you in part by Airbnb. Scotty and I had a couple of friends in recently, actually more than two, and they rented an Airbnb because we didn't have the space for them. And we went over there and it was like beautiful. It was gorgeous. And I was like, wow, I can't believe people rent their
Audible.com 斜杠 smartless。Smartless 部分内容由 Airbnb 赞助播出。斯科蒂和我最近接待了几个朋友，实际上不止两个，他们租了一套 Airbnb，因为我们没有足够的空间招待他们。我们过去看了看，简直太漂亮了。美极了。我说，哇，真不敢相信人们会把自己的
places out like this. And they do because it's such a good idea. I don't know, maybe you've stayed in an Airbnb before and thought to yourself, this actually seems pretty doable. Maybe my place could be an Airbnb. It can be as simple as starting with a spare room or your whole place when you're away.
房子租成这样。他们确实会这么做，因为这是一个太棒的主意了。不知道你以前有没有住过 Airbnb，心里想过，这其实看起来挺可行的。也许我的房子也可以挂在 Airbnb 上出租。其实很简单，可以从一间空房开始，或者在你外出时整套出租。
You could be sitting on an Airbnb and not even know it. Maybe you're planning a getaway this year. While you're away, you could Airbnb your home and make some extra money toward the trip. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.ca slash host. All right, back to the show. John, you know, all of your music,
你可能正坐拥一套 Airbnb 而浑然不知。也许你今年正计划度假。在你外出期间，你可以把家挂在 Airbnb 上出租，为这次旅行赚取一些额外的收入。你的房子可能比你想象的更有价值。访问 airbnb.ca 斜杠 host 了解具体价值。好了，言归正传。约翰，你知道，你的所有音乐，
every single time like we're talking, we see ET or Schindler's List or Raiders of the Lost Ark or whatever it is. Star Wars, keep going, sorry. Star Wars, Star Wars, Star Wars, Star Wars 4, 5, 6, Star Wars 7, 8, 9. Evokes emotion, right? A very deep emotion.
每一次就像我们谈论的那样，我们看到《E.T.外星人》、《辛德勒的名单》、《夺宝奇兵》或无论什么作品。《星球大战》，继续说，抱歉。《星球大战》、《星球大战》、《星球大战》、《星球大战》4、5、6、7、8、9。都会唤起情感，对吧？一种非常深厚的情感。
Is there a piece of music that you've written, or another composer has written, that to this day affects you emotionally, every single time, like your music does to me and us? Oh, that's so difficult. Beethoven 9th, Ode to Joy. I start there, I guess. One thing I wanted to add about the five note signal,
有没有哪段音乐，是你自己写的，或者是其他作曲家写的，直到今天依然能在情感上触动你，每一次都如此，就像你的音乐对我和我们所做的那样？哦，这太难了。贝多芬第九交响曲，《欢乐颂》。我大概从那里开始吧。我关于五个音符的信号还想补充一点，
which is an after the fact rationalization, but you have what is, But you have what is, re do do, do, sol, okay? Re do do, that's the tonic note. Do, again the tonic note down, and sol. Sol in music, which is the fifth degree, is an equivalent in language to a conjunctive but or and. So if I say da da da ba ba, that's not over with.
这是一种事后的合理解释，但你有……但是你有……re do do，do，sol，对吧？Re do do，那是主音。Do，又是下行的主音，还有 sol。Sol 在音乐中，也就是第五级音，在语言中相当于连词“但是”或者“和”。所以如果我说“哒 哒 哒 巴 巴”，那还没结束。
Right, right. If I do da da da ba ba, that's five one, that's six. Da da da da. So you're soliciting a response. Right. Da da da da da. Would be the end, would be a period. But what this does is da da da, oh, oh, maybe.
对，对。如果我做“哒 哒 哒 巴 巴”，那是五到一，那是六。“哒 哒 哒 哒”。所以你在寻求回应。对。“哒 哒 哒 哒 哒”。将是结尾，将是一个句号。但这个做的是“哒 哒 哒”，哦，哦，也许吧。
Yeah. Yeah. It's a, and so on. It's really interesting, yeah. You're asking for a response from the ship. It's what you remembered as a child, somehow, that you know it's not a sentence, it's part of a sentence. It's an ellipsis, yeah.
是的。是的。这是一个……等等。这真的很有趣，是的。你在向飞船索取回应。这是你作为小孩子时所记住的东西，不知怎么的，你知道这不是一个句子，它是句子的一部分。这是一个省略号，是的。
But it's not a complete sentence. I think once you realize that, there's great power in the fact that it doesn't settle. Yeah, it's a... No, that makes a lot of sense. You can almost, it's a musical version of a hand being left out. An olive branch. Reaching for someone.
但它不是一个完整的句子。我想一旦你意识到这一点，它没有尘埃落定这一事实本身就具有巨大的力量。是的，这是一个……不，这很有道理。你几乎可以……这就像是一只悬在空中的手的音乐版。一根橄榄枝。向某人伸出。
Yeah, like come back to me or grab this, let's unite. It absolutely works and you don't need to think about it. It does that for us. Yeah, that came across. John, I have a question from my husband, Scotty, who is a self-proclaimed expert on just about everything you've ever composed and or recorded, it's true.
是的，就像回到我身边或者抓住这个，让我们团结起来。它绝对管用，而且你不需要去思考它。它对我们就是有这种效果。是的，那种感觉传达出来了。约翰，我有一个来自我丈夫斯科蒂的问题，他自称是你创作和/或录制过的一切事物的专家，真的。
It's totally true. He says, this is from Scotty, there's been a long-standing rumor over many years that you played piano for the soundtrack recording sessions for the film version of West Side Story. Is that true? Yes. So that's you on the album playing piano? Yes. That's crazy. That is crazy. I played that in the pit a long time ago and it's really,
完全是真的。他说，这是斯科蒂提出的，多年来一直有一个长期的传闻，说你曾为电影版《西区故事》的配乐录音室弹过钢琴。这是真的吗？是的。所以专辑里弹钢琴的那个人是你？是的。这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。我很久以前在乐池里弹过那个，它真的，
really hard. Yeah, it is. Especially the prologue is just all over the place. Especially at a dinner theater it was tough because you got mashed potatoes thrown at you. Wait, John, it is true. I think a lot of Lenny's music was awkward, frankly. You've played it so you know why and how that is said.
真的很难。是的，确实如此。特别是序曲部分，简直毫无规律可言。特别是去晚餐剧场演出时太难了，因为会有人朝你扔土豆泥。等等，约翰，这是真的。坦白说，我觉得伦尼的很多音乐都很别扭。你弹过，所以你知道为什么以及人们为什么会这么说。
But it's a lot of part of the animated energy that he left in his music. Yeah, yeah, for sure. John, when you first started, first of all, you grew up in, tell me where you grew up again, Brooklyn? We're in Queens, Long Island. Queens, Queens, Queens. And then when you studied jazz as a kid,
但这很大程度上构成了他留在音乐中的那种生动的活力。是的，是的，当然。约翰，当你刚开始时，首先，你在……告诉我你是在哪里长大的，布鲁克林？我们在皇后区，长岛。皇后区，皇后区，皇后区。然后当你还是个孩子时学习爵士乐，
did you always know that, like when did the love of film composing come in? Like did you always want to do that or were you happy being a musician on Broadway and theaters and gigs? I never frankly planned to develop as a film composer at all. My father was, one of the things that he did in his professional life as a musician,
你一直都知道……比如你是从什么时候开始对电影配乐产生热爱的？你是一直想做这个，还是在百老汇、剧院和各种演出里当个音乐人就很满足了？坦白说，我从未计划过要成为一名电影配乐家。我的父亲……他在专业音乐人生活中做的事情之一，
was to play in Hollywood studio orchestras. And so as a teenager, and I was a serious piano student, I really wanted to be a concert pianist. He took me to recording sessions in the studio, and I became fascinated by what people were doing to score the films, how it was orchestrated, written, and so on. Wow. And eventually, how it was orchestrated, written and so on. Wow.
就是在好莱坞录音室乐队中演奏。因此，作为一个青少年——我当时是一个认真的钢琴学生，我真的想成为一名音乐会钢琴家——他带我去录音室的录音现场，我开始对人们为电影配乐所做的事情、它是如何被配器、编写等等感到着迷。哇。最终……它是如何被配器、编写等等的。哇。
And eventually, my job was playing piano in those orchestras. You mentioned that I played in Western Story. I also played way back, Some Like It Hot. Do you remember that? Yeah. That was you playing in the movie? Yes, I played on that.
最终，我的工作就是在那些乐队里弹钢琴。你提到我在《西区故事》里弹过。我很早以前还弹过《热情似火》。你还记得那个吗？记得。那是你在电影里弹的吗？是的，我参与了那部电影的演奏。
And the apartment, do you remember the apartment? Yes, yes. Yeah that. And the apartment, do you remember the apartment? Yes, yes. Sure. Yeah, Promises, Promises is based on the apartment. And Fred Astaire and Audrey Hepburn in Funny Face. So my introduction to writing for film was through the influence of older colleagues for whom I played the piano. And they said, can you orchestrate?
还有《公寓春光》，你还记得《公寓春光》吗？记得，记得。是的，那个。还有《公寓春光》，你还记得《公寓春光》吗？记得，记得。当然。是的，《甜心女郎》就是根据《公寓春光》改编的。还有《甜姐儿》里的弗雷德·阿斯泰尔和奥黛丽·赫本。所以我涉足电影配乐是通过那些我为他们弹钢琴的老同事的影响。他们问你会配器吗，
And I said, yes, well, here's a piece for next Tuesday, orchestrate this for me, which I did. And then just at that point in my development, television became very, very popular. And I did a lot of television, Alcoa Theater and Chrysler Theater, and all those things. And as Will said, Gilligan's Island, it's crazy that you wrote music for that. And were you happy to move away from television and the Kola Theater and Chrysler Theater. Yeah, and as Will said, Gilligan's Island.
我说会，好吧，这里有一首下周二要用的曲子，帮我把它配器，然后我就做了。就在我发展的那个阶段，电视变得非常非常受欢迎。我做了很多电视剧，比如《铝业剧场》和《克莱斯勒剧场》，诸如此类。正如威利所说，《吉利甘岛》，你为那个写过音乐真是太疯狂了。你当时乐意离开电视界、《铝业剧场》和《克莱斯勒剧场》吗？是的，正如威利所说，《吉利甘岛》。
It's crazy that you wrote music for that. And were you happy to move away from television again? Or did you like that? Must be such a faster process, of course. Time-wise must have been. Oh, it was such a slow, unplanned process, I must say. Really? Moving from television to feature films.
你为那个写过音乐真是太疯狂了。你当时乐意再次离开电视界吗？还是你挺喜欢那样的？过程肯定快得多，当然。从时间上来说一定是这样的。哦，不得不说，那是一个非常缓慢、毫无计划的过程。真的吗？从电视剧过渡到故事片。
I think at that time in my life, it was wonderful because I had so much more time to work on the feature film. Television show, if you did Alcoa Theater, for example, it was an hour show, which you would have to write it within a week, 25 minutes of music or so, orchestrate it and conduct it. And so that was hard.
我想我生命中的那个阶段，这太棒了，因为我有更多的时间来创作故事片。电视节目，比如你拍《铝业剧场》，那是一个小时的节目，你必须在一周内写完大约25分钟的音乐，完成配器并指挥。所以那很难。
To do a feature film, may have 25 or 30 minutes of music, but you have six weeks to do it, or a higher fee, a better orchestra and so forth. So it was a gradual step up that was evolutionary rather than anything planned. And is it true you can play six instruments? I read piano, bassoon, clarinet, cello,
制作一部故事片，可能只有25或30分钟的音乐，但你有六周的时间来完成，或者有更高的酬劳、更好的乐队等等。所以这是一个循序渐进的过程，与其说是有所计划，不如说是自然演变的。传闻你能演奏六种乐器，是真的吗？我读到的是钢琴、大管、单簧管、大提琴、
trombone and trumpet, is that right? It's incorrect on all counts. Thank you. I tried to play all of them. I spent time with piano, of course. One of the things I love so much about listening to classical music is that it is the closest thing we have to a time machine
长号和小号，是这样吗？完全不准确。谢谢。我尝试过演奏所有这些乐器。我当然花时间练过钢琴。我听古典音乐时最喜欢的一点是，它是我们拥有的最接近时间机器的东西，
because reading that music, playing that music note for note verbatim is exactly how they heard it, save the conductor adjusting time or pacing or whatever, is exactly what they heard 200, 300, 400, 500 years ago. And those were their rock concerts. That was, and so when you're sitting there, you're listening to one of these orchestras play these,
因为阅读那些音乐、逐字逐句地演奏那些音乐，与他们当时听到的完全一样——除了指挥调整节奏、速度或其他什么——这与他们200、300、400、500年前听到的一模一样。那些就是他们的摇滚音乐会。那就是……所以当你坐在那里，听着其中一个乐队演奏这些，
one of these pieces of music, it's as close to the exact experience people in the past had in anything we can do, I think. It's a very unifying thing. One of the things that draws our humanity, conceals it. I think what you say about listening presents something very hopeful, I think, about music. We've mentioned before that it's not language,
演奏这些音乐作品之一时，我认为这可以说是我们所能做到的、最接近过去人们所获得的确切体验的经历。这是一件非常具有凝聚力的事。这是凝聚我们的人性、使其隐而不露的因素之一。我认为你对倾听的看法，展现了关于音乐的一些非常充满希望的东西。我们之前提到过它不是语言，
it's something general. It may be in the end that Bernstein was right that it is international, it goes beyond language. We're talking about the divisions of the Oxford and Fifth and the Fifth being the conjunctive. It's something that I think we can place a little hope in, that it's something we all may share at an intellectual level that isn't particularly linguistic. Is there a piece of music that you've written, and now I'm gonna get into the sort of regrets,
它是某种普遍的东西。最终伯恩斯坦可能是对的，它是国际化的，超越了语言。我们刚才在谈论五度音和五度音的划分，五度音作为连词。我认为我们可以把一丝希望寄托在这一点上，即这是我们在一种并非特别语言化的智力层面上可能共同拥有的东西。有没有哪段音乐是你写过的——现在我要进入“遗憾”环节了，
do you have something that you've listened to and you go, I wish I had just done it like this, like that you've driven home from recording, you know, you've just scored a thing that we all are really familiar with, but when you were driving home, you thought, I wish I had done it a little bit differently. Do you have any regrets in that way?
你有没有什么听过之后会想，我真希望当时就那么做……比如你从录音室开车回家的路上，你知道的，你刚为一段我们都非常熟悉的音乐做完配乐，但当你开车回家时，你心想，我真希望当时能做得稍微不同一点。你在那方面有什么遗憾吗？
Yeah, because as actors, we do that all the time. Yeah, we do it all the time. I wish I had done this scene. Oh, you know, sometimes you drive home and you get into your driver and you go, oh, that's what the scene was about. When you see it finally. Or when you see it finally up on the screen.
有的，因为作为演员，我们一直在做这种事。是的，我们一直在做。我真希望我拍了这场戏……哦，你知道，有时你开车回家，坐到驾驶座上，然后你会想，哦，原来那场戏是这个意思。当你最终看到它的时候。或者当你最终在银幕上看到它的时候。
Yeah, we all do it. We all do that. It's absolutely, wish that could be better, or a change of note or phrase or whatever timing. Absolutely. You know, John, we didn't even touch on your time in the military, the US Air Force. Nor have we touched on golf.
是的，我们都会这样。我们都会这样做。绝对会，真希望当时能更好一点，或者改变一个音符、一个乐句或任何时间点。绝对如此。你知道，约翰，我们甚至还没有提到你在军队、美国空军的时光。我们也没有提到高尔夫。
Or golf, yes, but really quick. So many of your themes, especially Raiders and Superman and the Darth Vader theme, they're all very militaristic. They're very March, they feel like they, is that inspired by your time in the military or is that just what was required for the film? I think probably the latter, what was required at the moment.
或者高尔夫，是的，不过长话短说。你的许多主题曲，尤其是《夺宝奇兵》、《超人》和达斯·维达的主题曲，都带有很强的军事风格。它们非常像进行曲，感觉它们……那是受到你在军队时光的启发，还是仅仅是电影的要求？我想可能后者居多，是当时的要求。
Although one of the things that I did have wonderful opportunity in service to orchestrate for military band, because there were not a lot of publications for that instrumental combination available beyond Sousa and a few other earlier lights. Were they any good, those bands? Oh yes, well presently, our military bands, Marines and Army in Washington are superb.
尽管我在服役期间确实有一个绝佳的机会为军乐队进行配器，因为除了苏萨和少数其他早期亮眼作品之外，并没有太多适用于该乐器组合的出版物。那些乐队水平高吗？哦，是的，目前我们的军乐队——华盛顿的海军陆战队和陆军乐队都极其出色。
Superb, yeah. The Marine Band in Washington, there's a brass section that is equivalent to the Chicago Symphony. I mean, it's not an exaggeration to say. Wow, wow, that's cool. It's absolutely fantastic. Our principal trumpet, Tom Hooten in LA Philharmonic
极好，是的。华盛顿的海军陆战队乐队，有一个铜管声部，相当于芝加哥交响乐团。我是说，这绝不是夸张。哇，哇，太酷了。简直棒极了。我们在洛杉矶爱乐乐团的首席小号汤姆·胡滕（Tom Hooten），
is the former Marine trumpeter. He did, I don't know, two or three years in the Marine band there, and then came here and auditioned and won Los Angeles Philharmonic. So it's been a big tradition in our country, band to band tradition. Tell me about this wonderful routine you have at our, where Will and I are also at the same golf course
就是前海军陆战队小号手。他在那里的海军陆战队乐队待了大概两三年，然后来到这里试镜，并赢得了洛杉矶爱乐乐团的职位。所以这是我们国家的一个巨大传统，乐队到乐队的传统。跟我讲讲你在我们那里那种美妙的日常吧，威利和我也在同一个高尔夫球场，
that you play at and we will see you almost every day about four or five o'clock, you'll take the cart down to the bottom of the hill in the first hole, you'll park it and then you will walk the rest of the hole, play your ball out. Do you go onto the second hole, or is that enough, and is it just a sort of a meditative, wonderful routine? Because it's just-
你也在那里打球，我们几乎每天下午四五点都会看到你，你会开着球车去第一洞的山脚下，停好车，然后步行走完剩下的球洞，把球打完。你会去第二个洞吗，还是那样就够了？这只是一种冥想般美妙的日常吗？因为这只是——
We're not stalking you, but we have seen you. Oh, it's always such a thrill. Everybody always stops and says, hey, look, there he is. I've been going off there for, I don't know, close to 50 years. You would never know it by the way I play. I never did play well, it's gotten worse over the years. You work too hard.
我们不是在跟踪你，但我们确实见过你。哦，那总是让人激动不已。每个人都会停下来喊，嘿，看，他就在那儿。我去那里打球已经有……我不知道，快50年了。从我的球技上你绝对看不出来。我从来没打好过，而且这些年越来越糟了。你工作太努力了。
But I sit all day at the piano from early in the morning, lunch, just to keep working. So I had to keep this old bag of bones moving, I have to walk. And I'm living very close to the course, so I can go up there and walk for an hour. I try to walk for an hour, so that could be holes one, two, three, and four,
但我整天都坐在钢琴前，从清晨到吃午饭，只为了继续工作。所以我得让这把老骨头动起来，我必须走路。而且我住得离球场很近，所以我可以去那里走上一个小时。我尽量走一个小时，所以可能是第一、二、三、四洞，
or one, two, six, and seven, depending on the traffic and so on. That's good. And I get a cart so that I can stay out of the way of people like you guys who can really play. Well, and that first hill's kind of a bear. But you're always alone, which I love, because I'm a bit of an alone guy myself.
或者第一、二、六、七洞，这取决于球场上的人流量等等。挺好的。我租一辆球车是为了避开你们这些真正会打球的人。而且那座第一山坡简直像个硬茬。但你总是独自一人，我太喜欢这样了，因为我自己也算是个喜欢独处的人。
Is that on purpose, or is that just because you don't want to schedule around anybody else? It's very relaxing. You don't have to entertain anybody or be entertained. I can mull and meditate things flashing through my mind. But you gotta know that we play, Jason plays with people all the time and he never entertains them.
那是故意的，还是只是因为你不想迁就别人的时间？这非常放松。你不需要招待任何人，也不需要被招待。我可以沉思和冥想脑海中闪过的各种思绪。但你得知道我们打球……贾森经常和别人一起打球，但他从来不招待他们。
Yeah, very consistent. It's, yeah, that's possible. And also, any golf course, such a piece of beautiful work, particularly when there's nobody on it. You can see the contours of this glorious green. It's a big park. It's a beautiful invention. Greatest possible luxury in a crowded urban area.
是的，非常一致。这……是的，这倒有可能。而且，任何高尔夫球场都是一件如此美丽的艺术品，特别是当上面空无一人时。你能看到这片壮丽果岭的轮廓。这是一个大型公园。这是一个美丽的创造。在拥挤的市区里这是最奢侈的享受。
It's incredible. I've gotten quite, I've been doing it two, I think I've told you this, JB, I'll go sometimes on a Sunday afternoon by myself and then just strap my bag on and just walk by myself and play nine holes at sort of three, four o'clock. It's my favorite, yeah, it's my favorite thing to do. Yeah, it's just so good.
太不可思议了。我已经变得相当……我一直在这么做，已经有两年了，我想我跟你说过这个，JB，有时我会在周日下午独自一人去，然后把球包背上，独自步行，在大约三四点钟打完九个洞。这是我最喜欢的……是的，这是我最喜欢做的事。是的，感觉太棒了。
Great recreation. Next time we see you out there, fair warning, I'm gonna run up and give you a handshake, a hug, or a tip of the cap or something. Oh, great, love it. Yeah. John, thank you for being here today. Thank you so much.
绝佳的休闲方式。下次我们在球场上见到你，友情提示，我要跑过去跟你握手、拥抱，或者向你举帽致意什么的。哦，太棒了，求之不得。太好了。约翰，谢谢你今天来到这里。非常感谢。
You know, this is like one of my, you're such a massive inspiration This is like one of my, you're such a massive inspiration to me as a pianist, as a wannabe composer in my early 20s to everything you've ever done. And you know, I always say I want to retire when I'm 60 and then I start looking at your resume and I get a second wind.
你知道，这就像是我的……你是一个巨大的灵感来源……这就像是我的……你对我影响太大了，作为一个钢琴家，作为一个20出头想成为作曲家的人，以及你做过的一切事情。而且你知道，我总是说我想在60岁时退休，然后我开始看你的履历，我又重燃斗志了。
Because I'm just like, it's just unbelievable. Think about all the incredible work we wouldn't have had he stopped at 60. Yeah, it's- It should be noted, John, and Sean might not say this because he's embarrassed, but there have been, in the 20 plus years that I've been friends with Sean, there have been too many times to remember
因为我只是觉得……想想如果我们没有在他60岁时停下，我们会失去所有这些不可思议的作品。是的，这——应该指出的是，约翰，肖恩可能不会说这个，因为他很害羞，但在我和肖恩认识的20多年里，有太多次我记不清了，
the times that he's referenced, mentioned you, referenced your music, referenced what you've done. It's absolutely incredible. And I know it's such a thrill for him that you're here. And for us as well. I guarantee you he's 10 seconds away from tears. Yeah, he truly is. I'm gonna hold it in.
他提起过你，提到你的音乐，提到你做过的事。这绝对令人难以置信。我知道你能来对他是多么巨大的喜悦。对我们所有人也是如此。我敢打赌他距离哭出来只有10秒钟了。是的，他真的快哭了。我要忍住。
You've had a real impact on this young man's life. Yeah, you have. And mine as well. And Scott has too. You have created my love of classical music because of what you've done for. But not mine. Not true.
你对这个年轻人的生活产生了真正的重大影响。是的，你确实有。对我的影响也是。斯科蒂也是。因为你做的事，你培养了我对古典音乐的热爱……但不是我。才不是。
Not true. That was my entry point to it, was just being such an incredible fan of movies and focusing on the music and what that does and then discovering classical music and I listen to it all day every day. There'll never be another one like you ever. Well, thank you, Jess, so much for this.
才不是。那是我的切入点，仅仅是因为我是电影的超级粉丝，关注音乐以及它所起到的作用，然后发现了古典音乐，我整天都在听。永远不会再有第二个像你这样的人了。好吧，杰斯，非常感谢你。
I've enjoyed it, all three of you. Well, it's been an absolute pleasure. Don't even possibly think of 60 as an age to retire. No, no, I'm just throwing it out there. That's a teenager. Yeah. No, thank you, John. You guys have got years and years of productive work.
我很享受，你们三个人都是。好吧，这绝对是一种荣幸。千万不要把60岁当成退休的年龄。不，不，我只是随口一提。那还只是个青少年。是的。不，谢谢你，约翰。你们还有好多年好多年的产出期。
From your lips. And enriching everybody. You do, absolutely do. Enjoy. It's there. You have it. Thank you so much, guys. All right, pal.
借你吉言。并且丰富着每一个人。你们确实如此，绝对是的。好好享受吧。它就在那里。你们拥有它。非常感谢你们，伙计们。好的，老兄。
Great, great pleasure. Thank you, John. Love you to pieces. What a thrill. Thank you. Bye. That's how appropriate was that remark. Yeah, so listen, right as we were signing off,
太棒了，太荣幸了。谢谢你，约翰。爱死你了。真是一场狂喜。谢谢。再见。那句话真是太贴切了。是的，所以听着，就在我们挂断电话时，
he said to his assistant, he said, huh, so that was a pod. So he's now been, had an experience. Legend. Yeah, yeah. What I mean. He's just a legend. I'm really taken with that interview. I could have asked him so many things.
他对他的助手说，他说了句，哈，所以这就是播客。所以他现在有了一次体验。传奇。是的，是的。我的意思是。他简直是个传奇。我对那次采访真的很着迷。我本可以问他好多事情。
I know. You know, like, do you know that Steven Spielberg played clarinet on Jaws, but he played it so bad that they put the sound into the local marching band, because Steven, it wasn't great. So it's actually Steven playing, and it's some kid faking it in the movie. So funny.
我知道。你知道吗，比如，你知道斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格在《大白鲨》里弹过单簧管吗？但他弹得太糟糕了，以至于他们把声音放进了当地的军乐队里，因为斯蒂芬弹得实在不怎么样。所以实际上是斯蒂芬在弹，而电影里是一个小孩在假装。太搞笑了。
And then Steven played clarinet in 1941, the movie 1941, is that the movie? Yeah. Yeah, yeah. So funny. And then Stephen played clarinet in 1941, the movie 1941. Is that the movie? Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, and his son was the lead singer of Toto. Like we didn't even get to that. Who?
然后斯蒂芬在1941年的电影《一九四一》里弹了单簧管，是那部电影吗？是的。是的，是的。太搞笑了。然后斯蒂芬在1941年的电影《一九四一》里弹了单簧管，是那部电影吗？是的。是的，是的。不管怎样，他的儿子是 Toto 乐队的主唱。我们甚至都没聊到这个。谁？
His son. John Williams' son is the lead singer in Toto? Yeah. What? Oh shit. Yeah, swear to God. Why didn't you bring that up? Joseph, you always talk about your pocket.
他的儿子。约翰·威廉姆斯的儿子是 Toto 乐队的主唱？是的。什么？哦，靠。是的，天呐。你为什么不提这个？约瑟夫，你总是在谈论你的口袋。
You always talk about your pocket. I got 80 million questions I wanna ask. Why did you ask fucking one? I did, but I didn't want, we didn't get into his family. So I had. You got 80 million questions. wanna ask. Why'd you ask fucking one? We didn't get into his family. So I, and I wanted it to make it about him and you know, but I guess that is about him. That's his son. That's insane.
你总是在谈论你的口袋。我有八千万个问题想问。你为什么只问了一个该死的问题？我问了，但我不想……我们没有深入聊他的家庭。所以我……你有八千万个问题想问。你为什么只问了一个该死的问题？我们没有深入聊他的家庭。所以……我只想让话题围绕着他，你知道，不过我想这也是在聊他。那是他的儿子。这太疯狂了。
That's pretty cool. Yeah. Oh my God, you're right. He's kinda got the eye of the tiger. I can see that. His son. That's not Toto. Is it?
这挺酷的。是的。哦，天哪，你说得对。他有点那种“虎之眼”的神情。我看得出来。他的儿子。那不是 Toto 乐队。是吗？
Eye of the tiger, no. Toto's Africa. Well, who did Eye of the Tiger? Survivor. Survivor, yeah. of the Tiger, no. Toto's Africa. Well who did Eye of the Tiger? Survivor. Survivor, yeah. Really? Yeah, yeah. Guys, I've gotta go, but.
“虎之眼”不是。Toto 乐队唱的是《非洲》。那谁唱的《虎之眼》？生还者乐队。生还者乐队，是的。“虎之眼”不是。Toto 乐队唱的是《非洲》。那谁唱的《虎之眼》？生还者乐队。生还者乐队，是的。真的吗？是的，是的。伙计们，我得走了，但是。
All right. Okay. I don't think he ever, in Jaws, I don't think he ever scored the moment when Jaws actually took a bite out of anybody, did he? Bite! Wow, you really have to go. I really do, really.
好的。好吧。我觉得在《大白鲨》里，他好像从来没有为大白鲨真正咬任何人的那一刻配过乐，对吧？咬！哇，你真的得走了。我真的得走了，真的。
I love you both. Bite! And we'll see you next week on Smartless. Nobody wanted to say anything about my restraint. I had so many bits in there. We were talking about the Marines and their horn section. I was gonna say, Sean, you blew a Marine. All of them.
我爱你们俩。咬！我们下周将在 Smartless 节目中见。没人想对我的克制说点什么吗？我里面有那么多包袱。我们刚才在谈论海军陆战队和他们的铜管声部，我本想说，肖恩，你吹了一个海军陆战队员。全吹了。
And I never said it. Listener, please go to Smartless Extras for all of Will's bits from this week. I had so many that I didn said it. Listener, please go to Smartless Extras for all of Will's bits from this week. I had so many that I didn't do. You can only find an organ in a church. None of it. I didn't say any of it. Good for you.
而我什么都没说。听众朋友们，请前往 Smartless Extras 收听威利这周所有的包袱。我原本有那么多……我都没说。听众朋友们，请前往 Smartless Extras 收听威利这周所有的包袱。我原本有那么多都没说。你只能在教堂里找到风琴。全都没说。我什么都没说。做得好。
Love to love. Love goodbye. Bye bye. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Love goodbye. Bye bye. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
爱与告别。爱与告别。拜拜。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。爱与告别。拜拜。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Nancy's love story could have been ripped right out of the pages of one of her own novels. She was a romance mystery writer who happens to be married to a chef.
Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess 如果你喜欢 SmartLess，现在就可以通过 Wondry 应用或 Apple Podcasts 加入 Wondry Plus，提前收听并享受无广告体验。在离开之前，请前往 Wondry.com 斜杠 survey 填写简短问卷，让我们了解您。南希的爱情故事完全可以直接从她自己的一本小说里撕下来。她是一位浪漫悬疑小说家，碰巧嫁给了一位厨师。
But this story didn't end with a happily ever after. When I stepped into the kitchen, I could see that Chef Brophy was on the ground and I heard somebody say, call 911. As writers, we'd written our share of murder mysteries. So when suspicion turned to Dan's wife, Nancy, we weren't that surprised. The first person they look at would be the spouse. We understand that's usually the way they do it.
但这个故事并没有以“从此幸福快乐地生活在一起”结尾。当我走进厨房时，我看到布罗菲主厨倒在地上，我听到有人喊，快叫911。作为作家，我们写过不少谋杀悬疑小说。所以当怀疑转向丹的妻子南希时，我们并没有那么惊讶。他们调查的第一个人通常是配偶。我们理解通常他们就是这样做的。
But we began to wonder, had Nancy gotten so wrapped up in her own novels, There are murders in all of the books. that she was playing them out in real life? Follow Happily Never After, Dan and Nancy on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can binge all episodes of Happily Never After, Dan and Nancy, early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但我们开始纳闷，南希是不是太沉迷于自己的小说了——所有书中都有谋杀案——以至于她在现实生活中上演了这些情节？在Wondery应用或你获取播客的任何地方关注《从此不再幸福：丹与南希》。通过加入Wondery Plus，你现在就可以抢先且无广告地畅听《从此不再幸福：丹与南希》的所有单集。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。